Sam is a mythical and ancient deity
whose Origins may go back as far as 500
BCE when the earliest toan celebrations
took place in Celtic Ireland to
celebrate the end of the harvest season
and the beginning of the darker half of
the Year during the Gathering of the
Harvest neighboring hillsides were
illuminated with great bonfires which
families would use to light torches and
ignite their own he Fires at home which
some sources believe were to continue
burning until the Harvest collection was
complete their fires were said to keep
away evil spirits which was important
because this festival called for ancient
burial mountains to be open it was
believed that these mountains were
portals to the other world a realm
believed to contain Celtic deities and
spirits of the Dead on sin the veil
between the living and the dead would be
at its thinnest allowing them to cross
into the world of the living with
spirits and gods roaming free for an
evening a tradition was put in place to
appease them with offerings of food and
drinks in exchange for the survival of
livestock over the coming winter they
also built altars to honor their dead
ancestors composed of elements from the
natural world like colorful leaves
burning candles and symbols to
commemorate the death